hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram and this
is the Ingram angle from Los Angeles
tonight thanks for joining us on a very
busy Monday night
two tears of Justice that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
rabid radical left-wing activists are
out wreaking havoc on America again
now if you want to see what a deranged
violent modern day Brady Bunch might
look like well look no further than
these six antifa freaks
violent fiery riots destroying a police
car shattering Windows tons of graffiti
all but one of those arrested in Georgia
were out of Staters there will want to
be revolutionaries who traveled across
state lines to terrorize and they hope
to recruit and Inspire others
now the excuse this time was to call for
a night of rage and reciprocal violence
against police over the killing of an
activist named Manuel Esteban Tehran who
was fatally shot last week by police
after he shot a Georgia State Patrol
Trooper
well look
the antifa crowd did Inspire others
because 20 individuals gathered in
Boston supposedly over the weekend in
solidarity with the atlanta-based antifa
group and they did so by vandalizing a
public Bandstand with vile anti-law
enforcement graffiti and officers were
injured when they had to respond and
clear the area
and one of those arrested was the
daughter of democrat Massachusetts
congresswoman Catherine Clark
and Boston the daughter of house
Democratic whip Catherine Clark was
arrested during a separate anti-cup
protest over the Atlanta police incident
Riley Dowell faces charges including
assault with a dangerous weapon and
damage of property by graffiti after she
allegedly spray-painted a monument
before assaulting a police officer in
solidarity with the Atlanta rioters
now this individual pled not guilty and
was released the same day on 500 bail
now she's non-binary so expect a lot of
people are going to claim that a
lifetime of being bullied drove this
individual vigil to do it
but our justice department doesn't want
you to dwell on any of this not the
left-wing violence we're seeing
well organized with an interstate
component
done to obstruct law enforcement from
doing their jobs that's never going to
be considered the threat to society that
anyone who voted for Trump is
like the man who put his feet on
Pelosi's desk remember that picture on
January 6th well today he was convicted
on multiple charges and he faces a
maximum sentence of 20 years in prison
now mind you his most serious crime was
obstructing an official government
proceeding
now there were hundreds of people who
engaged in no acts of violence on
January 6 but who were branded domestic
terrorists in the media some of them
lost their jobs and generally had their
lives destroyed
I didn't even get to go back to work I
was fired from my job at Cook medical
and I'd been there 13 years and they
didn't even bother to ask me
what my part in that day was
dozens of those arrested were held in
solitary confinement for months and
conditions described as inhumane
they're about a little more than three
dozen at what I call the DC Gulag they
now have been locked down 22 hours a day
and their cells as they were initially
and we do have political prisoners in
the nation's capital that's not an
exaggeration
now still others with no criminal
records who had merely attended the
January 6 speeches they were treated
like anime combatants I was sleeping on
the couch and six o'clock in the morning
I hear Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom FBI open
the door open the door we'll knock it
down or something to that effect and one
was pointing an assault rifle at my head
about four feet away
meanwhile the only person who was shot
on January 6 was that unarmed woman
named Ashley Babbitt who was killed by a
U.S Capitol police officer
the doj closed that investigation in a
few months and determined that the
shooting was justified
I truly believe in my heart that they
know it's they know it's murder so I
mean they can't admit to it so they have
to just bypass it and blow by it and
just act like it never happened
heartbreaking and let's not forget the
summer of 2020 the so-called Summer of
Love when approximately two billion
dollars in property Devastation was done
now real clear investigations did an
in-depth analysis of January 6 versus
the summer of 2020 and here's some of
the highlights
the 2020 riots resulted in some 15 times
more injured police officers and damages
that were 740 times more costly than
those of the capital Riot dozens were
held in pre-trial detention for months
remember while the vast majority of
riders from the summer of 2020 had their
charges dropped
and at least 18 individuals lost their
lives in the name of supposedly peaceful
protests for George Floyd
so was Justice really done for these
losses
well we never really know
well let's not forget that lovely pair
of well-to-do young Manhattan lawyers
who firebombed a New York police car
they faced a maximum of 10 years in
prison but they had their sentences
downgraded to 18 to 24 months
and while we're at this conversation on
the Biden classified docs case
is the media really and truly going to
keep up the pressure to have standards
of Justice applied equally
all we know is that two and a half
months after those initial documents
were found the FBI still hadn't done a
complete surprise search of all of
Biden's homes and offices
was Jill's lingerie drawer rummaged
through like melania's was
and we're still waiting for those photos
of the Biden documents that are
collected and perfectly arranged for
photographers like they were at
Mar-A-Lago that was a photo op
now the likelihood of that happening is
about the same as the likelihood of the
Biden doj tipping off CNN to report live
from a raid of the home of atop antifa
organizer with dozens of FBI SWAT team
members in full Gear helmets and all and
helicopters hovering overhead
now the goal from January 7 2021 to
today
is to discourage conservatives from
getting involved
from any of you from attending rallies
or even publicly supporting strong
conservative candidates
The Not So implicit message is unless
you're an establishment Republican
thinks someone like Mitt Romney
unless you support gender fluidity in
all the curriculum schools and
transgenderism unless you supported the
coveted lockdowns and all the vaccine
mandates
you better watch your step
now you may be 17 or 70. and even if
you're not charged with a crime you
could be canceled you could be kicked
out of school you could lose a
scholarship or you could have your
professional World turned upside down
so none of us should be surprised that
so many Americans now believe that there
are two tiers of Justice in the United
States
a generally more lenient one for those
with the correct political motives and a
far more Draconian one for those who
supported president Trump or who simply
opposed the left's policies
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else